je
tu
nous
c'est un établissement qui est au coeur
de la cité de saint denis dont qui rend
compte aussi beaucoup de demandes de la
population du quartier donc on a
énormément de demandes pour entrer dans
cet établissement qui est quand même
connu et reconnu par la population
tunisienne qui est présent depuis plus
d'un siècle parce qu'il a quand même
traversé les âges et les époques et qui
elle d'abord été un hospice et ensuite
une maison de retraite dans les années
80 et qui aujourd'hui donc a subi une
réhabilitation pour pouvoir accueillir
les personnes âgées dépendantes et à
ceux atteints de la maladie d'alzheimer
et des troubles apparentés
et
yao
nous
on est à la proximité à la jonction
d'une
un couvent on va dire d'une congrégation
des soeurs de marie donc l'établissement
a grandi et évolué avec ces personnes là
aujourd'hui bon ces personnes ne peuvent
plus prendre en charge les personnes
âgées elles ont aussi vieilli la
dimension chrétienne est quand même très
importante et très présentes dans
l'établissement de part justement 7,7 ce
rapprochement est l'histoire qu'à
l'établissement avec ses avec ses soeurs
il y à une fois par semaine une
célébration c'est quand même très
important aussi pour les résidents et
certains sont très demandeurs aussi 2
sets à 2 cette approche s'est abaissée
de la dalle est à la baisse depuis tout
petit à la barre a toujours gardé ma
promesse avec dieu c'est pas ça je vais
aller à la messe
e
on travaille beaucoup et la philosophie
de l'humanitude avec eux
le besoin et la nécessité de laisser la
personne âgée debout au fil de la
journée et je trouve que le travail
accompli ici est vraiment fait dans cet
état d'esprit et dans la bonne ambiance
et dans la bonne humeur que ce reims 1 2
me n'est jamais bien loin
laissons l'avenir venir que sera sera
et moi mon avis ils sont devenus riches
y est alors son mari est mort si même il
ya déjà six ans et alors là je suis chez
moi comme ma maison
jeter a plus que dix ans que je vis ici
vous voyez alors ça fait que jamais
plaît beaucoup
et alors que chez lui chez comme
l'enfant de la maison
e
je
et si je m'occupe des espaces verts
et avant je travaillais alors j'étais
habitué avec
labbé a tué des plantes est où
maintenant j'occupe mon dans le plan car
tout s'est passé mais à l'intérieur il
était atteint du placement à m'occuper
de mes adieux alors au niveau de l'école
de saint françois
mon vol le en tant qu'animatrice
coordonnatrice 22 proposer des activités
à l'ensemble des résidents et de les
adapter
1 selon leurs attentes et leurs besoins
mais le but c'est de aussi bien sûr de
maintenir leur autonomie le plus
longtemps possible et c'est pour cette
raison qu'au niveau de l'ehpad de saint
françois
nous leur proposons toute une palette
d'activités des activités de bien-être
des activités de rencontres
intergénérationnelles et de rencontres
un tel établissement mais également des
sorties
voilà
du
tu
/
ouais